[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
émission ce soir largement consacrée aux
adieux du royaume uni à minuit les
britanniques auront officiellement
quitté l'union européenne le pays a été
sidéré déchiré et il aujourd'hui soulagé
après ce feuilleton interminable qui a
mis ses nerfs à vif la réponse de nos
invités dans un instant 47 ans
d'histoire commune et maintenant que
va-t-il se passer bien tout reste à
faire boris johnson et michel barnier
ont onze mois pour négocier ce divorce
historique à quoi vous ressemblez les
futures relations quitter le club a
forcément un coût
lequel on en parlera et qui mieux que
lui il peut nous aider à comprendre
cette page de l'histoire qui se tourne
et les journalistes il a basculé en
politique est aujourd'hui député
européen en marche
bernard guetta est notre grand témoin ce
soir voilà vous savez tout sans oublier
bien sûr notre club de chroniqueurs
comme tous les vendredis et ils sont
nombreux ce soir hashtag cvr n'oubliez
pas non plus c'est parti on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
à minuit à minuit précisément nous ne
seront donc plus que 27 l'union
européenne va perdre pour la première
fois son histoire
l'un de ses membres le royaume uni
bonsoir bernard guetta bonsoir merci
d'être notre grand témoin vous êtes
journaliste des années à la matinale de
france inter
vous siégez aujourd'hui à bruxelles dans
le groupe riou
c'est le groupe des marcheurs et vous
nous direz au fond comment vous avez
vécu cette semaine semaine historique au
parlement comment vous voyez la suite
robert frank bienvenus vous êtes
historien professeur émérite à la
sorbonne spécialiste de l'europe et des
relations internationales
elvire fabry bonsoir chercheuse senior à
l'institut jacques delors en charge des
questions liées à la politique
commerciale ce qui intéresse directement
les négociations en cours
et bien sûr le breakbeat enfin
j'accueille avec plaisir alex taylor
alex qui nous a fait vivre ce feuilleton
interminable dans cette émission vous
êtes chroniqueur entre autres ici même à
ça vous regarde et vous nous direz au
fond ce que le franco-britannique
ressent ce soir regardez les unes de la
presse britannique ce matin on en a
choisi de elle s'oppose yes we did it
daily express & small island c'est le
choix d'une gardienne small island
tout est dit je vous donne la parole
dans un instant juste après le billet de
stéphane blakowski qui va nous donner au
fonds sa vision le bras exit s'est tout
de suite
[Musique]
on sent une âme bonsoir messieurs
bonsoir c'est ça bonsoir bernard quand
même bon soir
alors si j'ai bien compris ce soir si
j'ai bien compris myriam on n'a pas fini
de parler du breakbeat
alors moi qui croyais qu'on ait enfin
sortir dans ces négociations
interminables auxquels plus personne ne
comprenait rien je crois que me suis
réjoui un petit peu trop vite
ah ça c'est mon côté naïf et je me
disais bon on nous dit que c'est le
break site aujourd'hui donc ça a pris
quatre ans ok mais ça y est ils sont
dehors au ferme la porte on n'en parle
plus vous imaginez le choc ce matin
quand j'ai regardé la une du daily
telegraph
avec boris johnson qui nous dit
exactement le contraire des six maps and
the beginning c'est pas à la fin du
breakbeat septembre le début dire que le
début du brics it's a déjà pris quatre
ans mais on va attendre combien d'années
pour voir la fin du breakbeat et à
attendait rassurez-vous boris johnson a
dit qu'il allait négocier des accords
économiques ça c'est ça maintenant plus
vite que l'union européenne plus assez
vite mais a mis le feu permettez moi de
vous répondre en joignant le geste à la
parole
mon oeil à mon ami rien il ya six ans
accord à renégocier que les britanniques
si monsieur le barney qui l'a dit donc
ça va certainement prendre plus qu'un an
d'ailleurs les européens eux mêmes
disent oui on aura certainement besoin
d'un petit peu rapide un petit rap de
négociation tu m'étonnes sont 27
personne n'est d'accord chacun des
intérêts différents avec une journée
historique pour moi c'est autre chose
on vit une journée historique ou pas du
jour historique le lendemain quand vous
réveiller le monde a changé
mais demain qui est ce que rafa changé
bah rien rien ou quasiment rien en fait
tant qu'on n'a pas signé d'accords
économiques
tout ça va continuer comme avant à
l'ancienne quoi quand même à chaque nom
la sortie des britanniques alors c'est
sûr je ne veux pas remuer le couteau
dans la plaie je sais que bernard et 106
mais c'est quand même une perte à 9,66
millions d'européens en moins la
deuxième puissance économique qui s'en
va son plan diplomatique bon balle et
les britanniques sont très forts
commonwealth le siège au conseil de
sécurité
il ya vraiment pas de quoi se réjouir
bon mais il ya charles michel lui qui
est président du conseil européen
donc il est un peu obligé de faire bonne
figure manquer il essaie de trouver un
aspect positif à cette histoire des
conséquences éventuellement favorable on
les écoute
le traité de divorce qui était une île
il ya peu de temps
ça sonne comme un rat diarra du réveil
pour l'union européenne et moi je sens
autour de la table concert op 1 les 27
chefs d'état et de gouvernement qui sont
prêts à se retrousser bien
les manches pour tenter davantage
coopérer de travailler ensemble
je sais pas moi cette comparaison du
break site avec le radio réveil je pas
sur mesure parce que ça ça suggère que
la lord endormi évidemment sur ses
lauriers sur ses lauriers jobin mais
vous imaginez quand même que l'on
compare souvent l'europe un grand bateau
est en train de dire parfaite l'équipage
s'est endormi sur la barre pour ça qu on
dérive un peu en ce moment mais ce que
c'est quand même un peu inquiétant cette
histoire de radio réveil n'en est ce que
le départ des britanniques pourraient
donner envie à d'autres de quitter les
adversaires de l'union alors en france
bien sûr ces rassemblement national qui
applaudissait ce matin demain bardella
était donc chez bourdin alors lui aussi
il trouve qui a un côté signal d'alarmé
dans leur excite mais par radio réveil
qui vous permet de commencer la journée
du bon pied
plus tôt la brosse sirène qui dit que le
bateau est en train de couler et qu'on
va tous crever on écoute moi je vous dis
aujourd'hui que l'union européenne on
est en train d'en mourir et que si on ne
change pas radicalement l'orientation de
la politique que l'on donne à la
construction open alors on mourra et que
toutes les grandes puissances
aujourd'hui partout dans le monde font
du patriotisme économique fondu pautric
sud protectionnisme et défendre leurs
intérêts d'abord un à l'entendre on
pourrait croire qu'ils aient souhaité
que la france qui comme il ya pas que
les grandes plaies qui tergiverse le
rassemblement national tergiverse pas
mal il était co entre maintenant ils
veulent plus sortir on dit ils sont pour
le break city se félicitent ils
applaudissent les anglais ils vont nous
dire
sortons nous aussi les français pas du
tout ça vous fait plaisir bernard d'être
d'accord avec le rassemblement national
j'imagine il ne veut pas sortir de
l'europe comme vous finalement bon
j'imagine que finalement au bape
continuer à voir puisque c'est que nous
ce n'est que le début comment se passe
que par exemple mais le meilleur
argument pour les européens pour les
convaincre effectivement qu'on ne faut
surtout pas quitter l'union européenne
ça serai et je sais vous n'êtes pas
comme ça bien là mais ça serait quand
même que le royaume uni fasse un break
si catastrophique et qu il se relève
jamais de la rhune çà çà çà çà çà c'est
un argument pour le retenant bernard
guetta une réaction à ce billet
malheureusement ces femmes à raison on
dit il ya quelque chose
d'extraordinairement il ironise
là-dessus mais je me connais il ya
quelque chose d'extraordinairement
douloureux dans cette affaire parce que
qu'ils pourraient dire aujourd'hui oui
hier d'ailleurs que la grande bretagne
ce n'est pas l'europe
évidemment que c'est l'europe évidemment
que c'est dans grande bretagne qui a été
réinventé la démocratie bien avant la
révolution française
évidemment que c'est en grande bretagne
que l'europe à trouver les forces de la
résistance au nazisme
évidemment que sanchez chill que sanchez
gil hitler aurait pu gagner évidemment
que nous somme toute je crois pouvoir le
dire que nous sommes tous plus ou moins
anglophile et pas seulement en grève car
pour vous cette meilleure neige mais je
vais vous dire depuis quinze jours et ce
n'est pas une formule c'est une réalité
les gens n'arrêtent pas de pleurer au
parlement européen alors évidemment ceux
qui pleurent le plus est cédé à ces
déchirants
c'est le député britannique est pas là
je ne parle pas des briques sitter
évidemment mais dans mon groupe par
exemple il y a les députés du parti
libéral démocrate
des gens profondément européen ce sont
les plus européens de tous les
britanniques et ses députés libéraux
démocrates qui sont des gens formidables
mais vraiment formidable depuis que je
suis au parlement j'ai travaillé
prioritairement avec les
libéraux-démocrates sur beaucoup de
dossiers est vraiment nous convergeons
tout le temps et notamment sur la
défense de l'état de droit et des droits
de l'homme parfait dans la presse il y
avait des indépendants qui disait si on
revenait un jour dans l'europe qui
n'avait une partie des britanniques
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à se résoudre'
imagine déjà le jour du mexique maroc
je vais vous livrer un petit scoop on ne
nous discutions dans le groupe renew
auquel nous appartenons nous les députés
français de la majorité présidentielle
nous y sommes mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
le jour où on vote
alors d'abord j'ai jugé que j'ai
commencé par dire écoutez moi vous êtes
je suis désolé mais moi je pourrais pas
dire oui aux eaux traitées
entre l'union européenne et la
grande-bretagne organisant le bac si je
ne peux pas dire oui parce que je pense
fondamentalement que le bât excitait une
quinte aso n'avait pas voté je me suis
abstenu je me suis abstenu je ne pouvais
pas voter oui je ne pouvais pas non plus
voté non parce que non c'était le cri
médias s'était bloqué donc sa jeune
enfance et vous que vous avez le
sentiment d'un immense gâchis à
m'écouter absolue et puis pour l'union
européenne
évidemment aussi sauf que sauf que en ce
moment et non pas grâce aux briques site
mais grâce si j'ose dire à monsieur
trump un consensus est en train de se
faire non seulement au parlement
européen mais aussi à la commission est
aussi au conseil c'est à dire
l'assemblée des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement autour de trois idées qui
hier était uniquement française est un
repoussoir pour tous nos autres
partenaires sans exception et ses trois
idées c'est la défense commune c'est
évidemment les investissements communs
dans les industries d'avenir et c'était
évidemment l'affirmation de l'europe sur
la la on va et vient sur la suite sur
l'avenir et comment peut-être le
président peut être un sursaut pour pour
l'europe reste un peu sur l'émotion
parce que des larmes
vous en avez déjà versé 1 avant même
cette journée fatidique du vote de
mercredi et minuit ce soir alex taylor à
qui à quoi vous pensez vous le
britannique qui a volé deux français à
cause de ça à cause du break site
je pense qu'en fait mon père pourquoi
est-ce que je suis si profondément pro
européen c'est parce que ma mère et mon
père a eu des médailles seconde guerre
mondiale et en dépit ou peut-être à
cause de ce qu'ils avaient vu dans ce
continent dès que son fils avait dix ans
la tenue à me montrer ce formidable au
continent faisait n'avait pas beaucoup
de moyens mais on faisait des détours de
camping avec une avec une tente par
partout pour que je vois l'europe et je
suis devenu profondément européen
pourquoi parce que aussi faux
on oublie souvent maintenant mais moi
j'avais 15 ans quand mon pays rentrer
dans le marché commun la grande bretagne
c'était l'homme malade de l'europe
on avait une crise économique il y avait
de l'électricité pendant trois jours
selon colin grève des mineurs
l'europe pour nous c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont passé dix ans à frapper à la porte
général de gaulle a dit non à plusieurs
reprises et pour nous moi je me souviens
les séjours linguistiques l'europe
c'est pour ça que c'est une question
d'identité pour moi moi le commonwealth
moi je m'en fous mais l'europe c'était
les séjours linguistiques c'était le
concours eurovision de la chanson c'est
à l'élysée le drapeau français plutôt
qu'à celle arbore depuis c'est bien
parce que je suis très fier d'être
devenu français mais tout simplement
fier d'être resté ce que je suis
profondément est ce que le bric site
m'arracher de forget avait même pas le
droit de vote dans ce référendum et mes
compatriotes sont vides terme et ex
compatriotes je suis aujourd'hui que
j'ai la double nationalité mais quelque
part je leur pardonne pas parce qu'ils
m'ont arraché un mois et la moitié faut
jamais oublier que la moitié si ce n'est
plus selon les derniers sondages les
britanniques se soit vont pas être là à
être filmée comme tous les gens qu'on
veut voir dans les médias parce que
c'était des génies qu'autour de giorgi
les big ben agitant des drapeaux etc
il ya une bonne moitié des britanniques
vont rester chez eux comme moi et font
pas car c'est incroyable parce que ne
pas pardonner ce hameau très très fort
il ya quand même un peu de soulagement
dans la population a duré tellement
l'union c'est un soulagement que c'est
une terre alors que sa fille fait que
quand même si je peux pas mettre ce
qu'il a dit c'est que c'est pas du tout
le président qui ne fait que commencer
cette année de la grande bretagne qui ne
fait pas tout de suite su tout de suite
dans un instant mais je voudrais d'abord
vous montrer ce reportage on a suivi les
derniers jours des députés britanniques
au parlement européen
les breaks zitter comme les rimes n
regardez ces signes et clément perreault
reportage une journée historique s'ouvre
parlement européen dans quelques heures
les eurodéputés vont voter l'accord de
retrait du royaume uni les stars du jour
ce sont eux les élus kubrick site partie
de nigel farage
bonjour martine salut comment ça va ça
va bien histoire c'est un grand jour
aujourd'hui
oui le grand jour le jour nous sortons
de l'europe
le dernier compte à rebours je suis
tellement impatient oui moi aussi on a
le vote cet après midi élu depuis six
mois ils n'ont jamais vraiment investi
les lieux
toutes mes affaires les voilà j'ai ça ça
ça mon ordinateur et quelques paperasse
et c'est tout je n'ai jamais fait cet
endroit ma maison car je n'ai jamais
voulu qu'il soit ma maison allez c'est
l'heure de partir dernière session de
l'autre côté du bâtiment
chris davis lui par pour l'hémicycle
comme on part à l'abattoir élu depuis
europhile convaincu il est dévasté par
la perspective du brics ça me brise le
coeur
le pays ne devrait pas quitter l'union
européenne nous devrions rester ici pour
préparer l'avenir
nous devrions essayer d'être des
décideurs pas des déserteurs pour
l'eurodéputé l'amertume s'ajoute à la
tristesse
[Musique]
je suis en colère contre boris johnson
et nigel farrage ces gens là sont des
démolisseurs ils nous empêchent de
construire l'europe et de travailler
tous ensemble ils démolissent tout
démolir c'est facile mais construire
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
dans l'hémicycle les eurodéputés votent
sans surprise l'accord est ratifié un
avantage aux seychelles autant d'attrait
des protestants et solennelle de
nombreux élus se lève et entonne un
chant britannique
chris davis vit ses derniers moments
dans l'hémicycle
au même instant à quelques sièges de la
les briques sitter quittent les lieux en
agitant l'union jack
[Musique]
victoire à baie mahault c'est une
émotion plein de joie mon coeur est
plein de joie parce que nous partout à
bruxelles le divorce est acté le royaume
uni ne siège plus au parlement européen
robert frank 47 ans d'histoire commune
c'est pas rien 47 ans d'histoires
parfois tumultueuse tout à l'heure
bernard guetta 10 et la grande bretagne
y mener c'est l'europe
vous êtes-vous d'historiens surpris de
la fin de l'histoire
cette séparation l'a surpris forcément
parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup une
accélération suivie des événements mais
ça fait pas 47 ans ça fait trois cents
ans et plusieurs siècles comme l'elysée
bernard guetta la grande bretagne et
l'europe scellier je vois qu'on fait
souvent pu rallier et oui bien sûr on
suit stoïquement l'amitié entre les pays
et shopi les rendez vous de l'histoire
et je sais ce que les britanniques
eux-mêmes oublie les britanniques sont
beaucoup plus européen qu'on leur îles
britanniques sont beaucoup plus européen
qu'il ne le croit la version sont dits
britannique a pas ils se sentent à part
ils se sentent a pas même ceux qui ont
voté remain se sentent à part bien sûr
ceux qui ont voté brice il se sent très
à part cécile talal à la différence
alors cela étant il faut bien comprendre
que les britanniques et l'europe depuis
300 ans ils ont toujours la même
attention si vous voulez une sorte de
tension entre une volonté d'indépendance
et une certaine idée de la grandeur ce
qui fait que même avant la construction
européenne ce qu'on appelle le concert
européen que deux britanniques ont
inventé un congrès de vienne en 1815 où
le système européen
les britanniques avaient la même
attitude c'est à dire quand ils sont
dans leur volonté d'indépendance faut
qu'ils ont plutôt envie de regarder vers
la porte de sortie
et quand ils sont dehors ils ont très
peur d'être marginalisés et de perdre
leurs ventes aux frais s'ils ont besoin
de cette de cette europe mode est au
fond lorsque la construction européenne
a commencé après la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est un peu le même scénario
d'où ces cycles 1 d'où ces cycles non
c'est vrai que la victoire de bronson et
était dans la défaite des rues mineurs
le 12 décembre 2019 du moins en
apparence et est cuisante donc le 6
cancan quand est-ce qu'ils vont revenir
parce qu'à mon avis vont venir vont
revenir
en fait c'était dans un siècle c'est à
dire 50 ans j'en sais rien c'est au tour
de quoi on se croisait marivin encore un
siècle
non non non non que j'aie de la dexc sa
peine c'est plutôt ne pas oublier que
cette victoire est énorme bruit johnson
et on va on va parler un peu plus ternes
au pied de son talent et de la façon où
sera négocié avec lui à partir du mois
de mars
il ya malgré tout 53% des britanniques
qui ont voté pour des partis contre le
brix et voilà les sondages semblent
montrer un bien sûr une campagne
électorale c'est vrai rien dit mais bon
là c'est ce qui fait de toi votre
émotion votre émotion bon c'est
l'émotion de 2 48% 50% 52% des
britanniques j'en sais rien mais c'est
l'émotion de tout un peuple le peuple
écossais est justement le auld lang syne
c'est un assez grand john barnes 1788
poète écossais très romantique qui là
aussi les peuples et cosec
je rappelle à voter email à rêver
d'indépendants 62% après remise juste là
dessus c'est qu'au fond l'union
européenne et moins affaibli que l'union
britannique ça qu'il faut bien
comprendre et ça ça va jouer daigle
accord avec les négociations qui vont
venir ça va jouer vous avez forcément vu
la une de l'express qui titre la vraie
victime dubrac site c'est l'europe c'est
pas l'idée même de l'europe qui en prend
un sacré coup aujourd'hui franchement
c'est vrai qu'avec ce break site
aujourd'hui la qui se réalise
il ya un sentiment de fragilité tout
d'un coup on se dit on se croyait on
croyait l'europe est éternel et c'est
vrai qu'il ya une ligne de faille ya une
ligne de faille et pour revenir
simplement sur l'émotion c'est vrai
qu'il ya tout le parcours historique qui
a tout ce qu'on a construit ensemble et
vous avez raison de revenir sur les
siècles qui nous qui nous précèdent
et puis il ya la réalité d'une de
quelque chose de très humain d'une
démocratie on parle du parlement
européen bien sûr mais c'est aussi une
démocratie sur le terrain c'est à dire
que quand on pense que en fait la
concrétisation de ce bric site entre
aujourd'hui et demain c'est la perte de
la citoyenneté européenne c'est à dire
qu'on a des conseillers britanniques qui
ne pourront pas se présenter aux
élections municipales dont
dans quelques jours sa valise 730
quelques élus les conseillers municipaux
qui sont britanniques et donc et en tant
qu'européens à la droite mais ça va très
loin parce que ça c'est de la vie
politique de terrain c'est de
l'intégration s'est on sait bien c'est
des familles c'est ça veut dire qu'on a
réussi à aller quand même très très loin
dans l'intégration de nos sociétés je
voudrais aller avec vous sur la question
de qui va se passer maintenant parce que
stéphane l'a dit voilà pour l'instant à
part ces députés britanniques les
fonctionnaires britanniques aussi qui
travaillent dans le cadre des
institutions européennes il rentre au
bercail si j'ose dire
mais maintenant une négociation commence
sur quoi précisément on a l'impression
que boris johnson est très clair il veut
obtenir le maximum en donnant le moins
possible est-ce que c'est comme ça vous
voyez les choses
oui mais j'ai envie de dire les
européens aussi et là la position de
bruxelles elle est très claire elle et
elle est ferme est les coopératives et
depuis le début ça a été dire on est au
vert pour avoir une
une relation qui reste la plus étroite
possible mais elle est très très ferme
c'était ferme sur l'indivisibilité des
quatre libertés pendant la période de
retrait
maintenant quand vous regardez service
d'action des personnes des services des
capitaux et des marchandises bien aidé
bien et quand vous voyez maintenant tout
ce que la commission européenne a mis
sur la table il ya un mot clé c'est
concurrence loyale l'avim playing field
c'est à dire que c'est pas simplement le
lait les normes techniques les parce
qu'évidemment tout ce qu'on apporte sur
le marché européen il faut que ça
respecte les normes techniques
c'est tout ce qu'il ya autour c'est tout
ce qu'on a construit à l'échelle du
marché unique
c'est toutes nos préférences collectives
en matière sur la loyauté ça veut dire
qu'on soupçonne boris johnson ne pas
vouloir être très loyal peut-être ben là
on sait très bien que pour barry johnson
l'a questionné son agenda à lui dans la
négociation ne pas chercher la solution
c'est là il faut pas oublier avec paul
johnson une seule réponse à tous vous
regrouper tout ce qu'elle est de l'idée
que les conditions de paris sonne c'est
très clair boris johnson donc c'est un
seul jour si vous et c'est quelqu'un qui
a qui a parlé contre le pack city à 6 7
ans si vous cherchez sur youtube vous
allez dire pis que pendre de dubai de
l'idée d'un brick city sont pragmatiques
quelqu'un qui devront absolument revenir
à la grandeur tourner vers des états
unis c'est quelqu'un qui veut y en ait
pu l'air c'est quelqu'un qui avant tout
tient à être populaire et à prendre des
décisions c'est pour ça que je pense que
c'est diminuer cette semaine avec 30
avec des états unis le fait qu'ils aient
choisi huawei contre l'avis de trempe ça
me laisse plutôt optimiste sur le fait
qu'en fait il va choisir pour avec
l'europe la solution qui tournent vers
la chine a serait peut-être pas non mais
je pense qu'il va choisir l'option avec
le moins de soucis pour sa popularité
c'est à dire si il opte pour un grand
deal avec les états unis ça veut dire
quand même beaucoup de chômage beaucoup
d'incertitudes pour le business
britannique
s'il reste dans un statut pour plus ou
moins avec giroud tarifs avec l'union
européenne
ça lui adouci c'est pour ça qu'il
voulait dire qu'elle s'étonne il veut
plus qu'on parle du break 6-3 ce que
quelque part
le bac c'est de salon merde qui a le
plus à perdre dans la négociation
franchement bernard guetta qui est en
position de force
écoutez les britanniques sont 60 et
quelques millions de personnes l'europe
ces quatre cent cinquante ou soixante je
le reste de l'europe pardonnez moi c'est
450 ou 460 millions je ne sais plus
exactement de deux citoyens évidemment
que c'est les britanniques il ya un
rapport de force mais pour en revenir à
votre question initiale ce qui est le
plus frappant c'est que depuis un mois
et demi à peu près depuis l'élection de
ben johnson en vérité jamais la grande
bretagne n'a été sur les grands dossiers
diplomatiques aussi proche des grandes
capitales européennes qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la grande bretagne fait
front avec les capitales européennes le
parlement la commission le conseil
contre contre qui contre monsieur trump
et contre les états unis
c'est vrai sur l'iran c'est vrai sur les
questions des relations commerciales
avec la chine c'est vrai sur la libye
c'est vrai ce jour quand on les fera
signer par donald
c'est vrai la personne mais pas la
vérité je n'ai même pas ça si ce sont
les intérêts d'état ce sont les intérêts
vitaux de la grande bretagne et les
diplomates et les hommes politiques
britanniques ne sont pas aveugles ils
savent très bien que monsieur train mène
le monde dans le mur aujourd'hui le mur
c'est peut-être un mot trop d'où
d'ailleurs m'enfin bon bref et que la
raison se trouve aujourd'hui dans les
capitales européennes et bien londres
nous rejoint tous tous alors pardonnez
moi de le dire mais la une de l'express
là j'ai rarement vu une telle sottise
robert frank
oui je crois qu'il faut comprendre boris
johnson faut comprendre aussi comment il
a gagné il ya deux grande bretagne de
royaume uni un clivage énorme et le
clivage chante la grande bretagne n'a
jamais connu un clivage aussi fort que
depuis chrome os est l'un des voiliers
cc bon voilà c'est celle affaire dreyfus
c'est finalement cela étant il y a dans
chaque camp des nuances il sauve briques
sitters et les hard et soft rumine aux
herbes et et le génie de bruit johnson
c'est d'avoir une image de l'arbre
excitant d'avoir signé à son site
mais comme il à lima la brique cedars
que n'avait pas theresa may il a fait
passer
et comme de l'autre côté les soft
ruminer son passé on veut plus en parler
ils ont lâché je ne dis pas que ç'a eu
la majorité alors qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer à une habilité politique
indéniable donc ça aurait pu coûter la
vie politique qu'est ce qui va se passer
maintenant parce qu'il est aussi très
habile parce que il peut pas contenter
tout le monde comme un jeu est dit il
faut bien qu'ils trahissent quelqu'un
est ce qu'il va trahir ceux qui sont
ultra libéraux comme lui mais dans ce
cas c'est complètement contraire à tous
ceux qui ont voté pour lui dans le nord
de l'angleterre dont elle a besoin du
libre échange est absolument besoin du
cheval trahis alors écrit avec sociale
et on ne peut pas voir libre échange en
même temps franchise fiscale c'est donc
qu'est ce qui peut faire il peut il a
intérêt à voir quelque chose de plutôt
soft pour avoir son libre échange pour
que les gosses ne semble
ne sont ils pas dire à son bras son
électorat mais ne vous inquiétez pas on
fera un global brut mais ça sera pas
dans l'accord et une fois l'accord signé
il fera ce qu'il veut donc donc il va
pas trahir les sobres excitant
il n'a pas trahir les abris sitters il
peut très bien trahir le traité lui-même
or oui il fait très bien ne pas
appliquer c'est à dire pourquoi pas
essayer d'avoir des ports francs etc
qu'est ce qui va se passer est ce que
l'europe pourra répondre c'est là le
piège dans lequel on peut signer un
accord déjà qu'il a besoin de le
respecter c'est le jeu mais alors
attendez attendez une seconde
réfléchissions cela règle de l'unanimité
là il a besoin de la réalité si l'europe
est unie contre lui ces mauvais contre
lui mais si l'europe est désunie c'est
encore pire pour lui puisqu'il faut
l'unanimité
mais une fois qu'ils à l'unanimité sur
le libre-échange qu'il veut après si
l'europe dit tiens il a trahi donc on
reprend des sanctions et oui mais ça va
être compliqué de prendre des sanctions
alors du coup l'arrivée l'unamité cette
fois on est en train de s'affaiblir
simple et donc voilà deux options de ses
maris on n'est pas dans la tête de boris
johnson et ombres ou est-ce qu'il peut
gagner sur tous les tableaux
ou pas non il n'y a aucune raison il n'y
a aucune raison on est en on est en rang
serré et côté européen et j'irai quand
on rentre dans une négociation de toute
façon voyez on canton comme ses
positions et la force de l'union
européenne
si encore une fois un cadre juridique
c'est à dire que c'est pas forcé il ya
des éléments de négoce qui se négocie
mais il ya surtout le respect d'un
certain nombre de principes juridiques
et qui font qu'on a vu d'ailleurs la
fermeté aujourd'hui un des trois
nouveaux visages ou sauna van der leyen
charles michel et
et monsieur sassoli le message est très
clair il n'est pas question d'ouvrir une
négociation en notre défaveur si je puis
dire
maintenant ce qui risque de compliquer
un peu les ce1 peu les choses c'est
d'avoir un boris johnson qui joue
l'ambiguïté
c'est à dire que au lieu d'avoir une
position claire comme on l'aimerait que
la semaine prochaine ils nous disent
voilà voilà jeu on va aller vers tel
degré divergences ou voilà ce qu'ont
cherché à partir de là qu'on puisse
construire quelque chose il va jouer
l'ambiguïté pour en effet ménager la
chèvre et le chou d'un côté et de
l'autre et pouvoir également et de la
même façon il risque avec les états unis
de jouer un petit peu sur cette même eau
mais il faut la paix devait remonter
chercheurs la dépendance économique du
royaume uni vise à bilal d'europe
l écologie énorme elle est colossal à le
suivre à l'écho la moitié des
importations
c'est la moitié des importations mais
surtout pour toi surexploitation surtout
au delà des importations de biens
l'économie britannique reposant 80% sur
les services et donc sur une proximité
géographique c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on peut substituer rapidement vers le
commonwealth où les états unis ou même
la chine et les services sont ce qui est
plus difficile à négocier dans les
accords commerciaux faut pas l'oublier
dont ma faim en train d'un gros plan et
continuer à parler de ses négociations
avec ce reportage toujours de clément
perreault sur la pêche
c'est l'une des causes du vote pour le
bras exit immense majorité des habitants
des villes côtières en angleterre ont
voté pour la sortie ce qui est en cause
c'est évidemment les quotas de pêche et
la négociation sur les eaux
territoriales reportage dans l'est du
pays
regardez lowestoft qu est la ville la
plus à l'est du royaume uni son visage
est celui d'une angleterre grise figé
bien loin des lumières de londres
et de bruxelles ici le break site a
obtenu 63% des voix au référendum de
2016 le port de pêche comptait 100 85
bateaux il ya trente ans ils ne sont
plus qu'une douzaine pour steven martin
le coupable est tout désigné rendez nous
nos eaux territoriales donnez nous plus
de poissons de toutes façons ils sont à
nous après tout ils viennent de nos zoo
donc il faut en finir avec les quotas de
pêche européens et faire remonter un peu
les primes je ne connais pas un seul
pêcheur qui ai voté contre le brésil
j'imagine que si j'avais voté contre je
ne serai pas un vrai pêcheur le break
site bouée de secours d'une angleterre
qui se noie c'est la vision de djoum
mairie la propriétaire du marché aux
poissons de la hausse toft au mois de
mai elle est devenue députée européenne
pour le parti de nigel farrage le pré xi
deux parties nous allons sortir de
l'union européenne et reprendre le
contrôle de nos zoo et faire revivre
toutes les villes côtières du
royaume-uni du cannabis avait créé très
bon pour nous je le sens nous avons
travaillé dur et maintenant c'est notre
moment notre mère est très précieuse
c'est l'une des plus poissonneuses au
monde mais la politique de la pêche de
bruxelles a juste été un désastre pour
nous en 2016
notre premier ministre de l'époque david
cameron a demandé à discuter avec eux
pour arranger les choses mais ils ont
répondu non
les accords de pêche entre royaumes unis
et union européenne doivent encore être
négociés john gomery nous montre le
centre-ville de lowestoft le spectacle
n'est pas plus réjouissant que sur le
port le supermarché du centre a fermé
comment les commerces autour peuvent-ils
s'en sortir ce magasin était là depuis
des années
fermer ici aussi nous avions un grand
centre commercial fermé le centre ville
se bat pour survivre
la principale raison à cela est le
manque d'argent et c'est en cela que le
break site est extrêmement important il
va ramener une industrie qui nous a été
volé l'industrie de la pêche et chasse
pêche m
brick site sera-t-il la solution miracle
pour cette angleterre là à lost oft un
sentiment prédomine
il n'ya aujourd'hui rien à perdre voilà
on entend les attentes et des breaks 7
heures qui vivent de cette pêche là
cette bataille de la pêche
pour moi ce reportage c'est vraiment un
crève coeur parce que on voit en gros
plan
tout l'illusion des gens qui ont voté
pour le back side
ils pensent que en sortant de l'union
européenne la grande-bretagne et donc
leurs villes leurs ports existants vont
retrouver ou trouver une prospérité
incroyable mais on a envie de leur dire
mais malheureux enfin le le poisson vous
l'industrialiser vous le mettez en
conserve et vous le vendez ou en vendée
où évidemment sur le continent européen
alors vous allez fermer ferme et se lie
cette libre circulation des marchandises
et vous croyez que vous allez retrouver
la prospérité comme ça le drame
le drame c'est qu'il n'ya pas un break
s'il ya au minimum deux breaks 6 il y a
le bric si des gens qui veulent en
retrouverez le mythe d'ailleurs d'une
grandeur passée parce que comme le
disait tout à l'heure
alex dans les années 50 et 60 la grande
bretagne était dans une crise économique
extraordinairement pour faire peu
importe mais il y a cette idée d'un mis
l'europe à casser une prospérité et on
va la retrouver et pia l'autre brixi le
break site des gens d ultra ultra
libéraux du parti conservateur qui
considère que même temps je n'avais pas
terminé le boulot et qu'il faut
continuer à déréguler des rennais reste
ou pas par de la protection du travail
de l'environnement absolument tout et
comme le disait un conservateur polonais
un de mes amis au parlement il me disait
mais oui si la grande bretagne suit ces
gens là ah oui ce sera singapour à
l'honneur et le bangladesh et le
bangladesh dans tout le reste de la
grande-bretagne fait que cette idée là
c'est ce break site puisqu'il ya
plusieurs fois il ya des grands
malentendus aussi au sein du pays
lorsqu'on met derrière de break vite
mais ce break 6 versions thatcher qu'il
faudrait se terminer le travail ultra
libérale de la city qui au fond
bénéficierait d'importation sans les
normes européennes j'imagine le boeuf
aux hormones la vache folle venue des
états unis avec cette idée d'un d'un
paradis fiscal aux portes de l'europe
c'est possible ou pas il me semble qu'un
grand fantasme autour de singapour sur
la liste eh oui oui parce qu'en fait
même on se dit que c'est d'abord un
paradis fiscal c'est vrai qu'on voit la
situation économique de singapour est
assez étonnante faut pas oublier d'abord
que c'est un régime très dirigiste très
dirigiste quand on regarde dans des
météorites heure limite complètement
autoritaire et par ailleurs que même en
terme de fiscalité fiscalité
d'entreprise
on est à 10 9% au royaume-uni on est à
17 % à singapour je trouve pas que le
différentiel soit colossal non plus
majeur c'est vrai qu'il ya une sorte de
projection de fantasmes un petit peu
avec actuellement un pays divisé en deux
entre les briques cité à la menace mais
comme vous le dites les briques sitter
sont complètement divisé m vous
alimentez s'entassent mais moi quand
j'entends dans une conversation le lit d
une sorte de conviction qui apparaît que
finalement boris johnson dans un très
bon négociateur
nous on est un peu des visées ci ont dit
nous pour les européens et que
finalement il a quand même
vous avez alors dire qu'il ya de bonnes
chances d'en tirer mai aps les avantages
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on dit d'aller
vite fait se méfier de lui pas leur
confiance et tout mais il faut
effectivement être faire il faut
effectivement parce que là aussi messi
tweet je le crains comme l'enfer mais
dans le détail lui s'il veut finir avant
on aura un accord très flou et si quand
il ya du flou c'est qu'il ya un loup et
le lieu c'est morrison
donc martine aubry la première question
peut-être pour conclure que thérèse
débat je vous donnerai la parole avec on
a parlé dans le biais de dell de
stéphane pardon d'une potentielle
fragmentation de l'europe c'est tout le
monde tout le monde se disent ah si à
long terme l'europe ou de l'om on y
croyait peut-être de l'europe si ça
marchait est ce que vous croyez que
c'est maryse la partie
les au jeu durera pas c'est une question
parce qu'on se dit en gros tout dépend
d'une certaine façon même jeu l'avenir
urban ne veut pas en hongrie ne veut pas
sortir les polonais certainement pas et
regardez marine le pen elle ne veut
garder de deux rounds soucis à une
équipe de l'euro donc le père dans ce
débat moi je la moyenne terme et le
royaume uni qui n'existera pas mon avis
dans 5 l en guerre n'ya pas l'irlande du
nord s'est réunifiée et puis dans dix
ans il n'y a pas les cosses alors ce que
deviendra dans quelques mois à l'est où
les britanniques le dise au parlement
européen absolument
on commence par la réunification de
l'irlande et ensuite les causes 125g
base ils ont raison c'est passé vers
l'indépendance peut-être et la grande
roue le morcellement l'alimentation du
royaume uni merci beaucoup d'être venu
sur le plateau de lcp débattre de ce
break site qui a lieu officiellement ce
soir à minuit
je vous propose pour terminer de ce
débat était parfait nos chroniqueurs
puissent venir sur ce plateau de
regarder à nouveau
et bien cette séquence au parlement
européen
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
voilà très impressionnantes images
regarder des députés britanniques qui se
tombent dans les bras de tristes est
cette fois ci on peut y aller
le bloc notes c'est parti et ils sont
très nombreux ce soir nos chroniqueurs
bernard guetta je vais vous les
présenter dans l'ordre l amont d'un gars
va bonsoir ravi de vous retrouver des
journalistes à lcp welcome back
bienvenue à la petite mohéli qui est née
il y a quatre mois maintenant
vous avez justement que le mouvement
social de l'histoire mais vous allez
vous rattraper parce que vous n'avez
nous parler de la guérilla parlementaire
contre la réforme des retraites qui se
prépare à l'assemblée nationale
géraldine woessner du point qui est
journaliste politique d'investigation
qui va pousser un gros coup de gueule ce
soir sur un amendement discuté hier à
l'assemblée nationale à camille vigogne
quote je commence par les femmes
messieurs en bleu michou et qui va nous
raconter
au fond les relations entre michou cet
homme cet oiseau de nuit avec les avec
les politiques michaud d'ailleurs dont
les obsèques ont lieu aujourd'hui
bertrand dicale bonsoir mon choix vous
allez nous faire chanter j'espère sur
l'actualité on va parler de gars enfin
mon cher camille j'espère que vous avez
préparé des petites surprises
oui vous allez voir ça va vous
intéresser alors on commence avec elsa
elsa on commence avec un chiffre 22 1159
exactement myriam 22 1159 et bien c'est
le nombre colossal d'amendements déposés
pour la réforme des retraites sont
examens commencent à l'assemblée en
commission lundi à titre de comparaison
la loi macron ces trois mille
amendements le mariage pour tous et cinq
mille amendements et en plus ici il
s'agit des amendements déposés en
commission pas en séance publique n'aura
plus encore sûrement on n'espère pas
mais on verra on est loin du record ici
à l'assemblée s'était 137 1665 c'est en
2006 pour la privatisation de gdf
attention ce chiffre de 22 1959 il peut
encore gonfler un pendant le week-end
puisqu'il n'ya pas encore les
amendements du rapporteur et du
gouvernement
donc c'est une vraie guérilla pour
retarder au maximum de textes de
l'obstruction et faire capoter le
calendrier de de ce gouvernement qui
veut qu'il veut faire adopter cette
réforme avant l'été alors tous ses
amendements qu'ils sont
les signataires principalement la france
insoumise exactement 19 1713 amendement
c'est à dire 90 % ont été déposés par le
groupe de jean luc mélenchon regardez
ces images que nous avons tourné à
l'assemblée i l est bien ce sont les
collaborateurs du groupe ils ont passé
la journée à déposer les amendements sur
le logiciel de l'assemblée c'est simple
ils ont proposé la suppression des
soixante cinq articles du projet de loi
et dans les articles la suppression est
bien de chaque alinéa on multiplie tout
ça par les 17 membres du groupe et on
arrive à des milliers des milliers
d'amendements alors face à ce
déferlement ça va évidemment rallonger
les débats même si on siège le week-end
ça va être difficile de tenir le
calendrier
dans la majorité on essaye de garder son
calme on prend acte
on dit qu'on va respecter le débat
démocratique mais on s'agace quand même
de cette stratégie
olivier veyrenc le rapporteur du projet
de loi organique dénonce un zadi sme
législatif et bien je ne la mets l'ajonc
il assume un de l'obstruction il en fait
c'est la grève du zèle
le zaïdisme législatif ça lui va bien il
prend l'expression au pied de la lettre
puisqu'il dit souhaiter à la réforme des
retraites est bien le même avenir que
l'aéroport de notre dame des landes
son abandon pur et simple vous avez un
regard comment sûr sur cette bataille
parlementaire à l'assemblée ça se passe
comme ça ou parlement offert non écoutez
moi j'ai pas encore vu ça peut-être que
ça arrivera j'en sais rien sont les
droits de l'opposition
chez les droits oui bien sûr est ce que
cette bonne guerre nous devons parce que
c'est pas très intelligent parce que
c'est pas sur le fond parce que c'est
pas un vrai débat c'est du de la
guérilla c'est autre chose c'est un
autre à mai au parlement européen il ya
aussi des bataille d'amendements mais
véritablement de fonds alors voilà il ya
vraiment de vrais vrai débat très
important
à propos d'un amendement de quatre
lignes et on se bat c'est vrai c'est des
vraies batailles politiques mais vous
savez au parlement européen moi je suis
depuis septembre seulement
le niveau est vraiment impressionnant le
niveau est vraiment impressionnant moi
je suis dans mes petits souliers basque
mais oui mais quoi
oui j'apprécie j'apprends véritablement
j'apprends dans un dépassement à la fois
des frontières nationales et des
frontières politiques parce que il ya
énormément de collaboration entre les
différents courants des différents
courants on peut faire de compromis
compromis à l'assemblée nationale
géraldine fait à vous vous allez nous
parler d'une proposition de loi et d'un
débat qui a eu lieu hier à l'assemblée
qui a énormément suscité de réaction de
polémique
il s'agissait d'une proposition de loi
destinée à allonger le congé pour deuil
d'un enfant de 5 à 12 jours elle a été
rejetée par les députés
oui sur un sujet aussi douloureux vous
imaginez l'émotion dans l'hémicycle le
député du nord lui dit guy bricout
voulait porter à douze jours ce congé
légal qu'on peut prendre quand son
enfant décède aujourd'hui ces cinq jours
c'est peu mais le gouvernement s'y est
opposé écoutez franchement je vous le
dis mes chers collègues je vous le dis
madame la ministre je pensais que sur ce
point là l'allongement en cas de décès
d'un enfant de 5 à 12 jours il y aurait
pas de france a soumises et il n'y
aurait pas de républicains et n'y aurait
pas de modem et il n'y aurait pas de en
marche
je penserai que sur ce dossier lors
marcher main dans la main quand on
s'achète de la générosité à bon prix sur
le dos des entreprises c'est quand même
un peu facile je me permets
je me permets je me permets s'il vous
allez on vous a écouté on a écouté
chacun cas là on peut tomber facilement
dans la caricature
on y évidemment n'y a pas échappé le
gouvernement il dit quoi il dit vous
voulez que les entreprises financent ce
congé supplémentaire c'est pas leur rôle
donc non à la place on propose que le
congé il reste à 5 jours mais derrière
ben on va pouvoir coller ses vacances
ses rtt aux besoins rtt donné par les
collègues on va encourager cette belle
solidarité au sein des entreprises
et c'est finalement dans cette version
gouvernementale qui a été votée alors
c'est peu dire que cette version elle
est moins 10 ans et ça montre à quel
point la majorité est hors sol sur
certains sujets parce que les don de rtt
les congés ça marche dans les très
grandes entreprises mais 8 millions de
français travaillent dans des boîtes de
moins de 50 salariés
ils sont près de 3 millions dans les tpe
10 salariés et leurs congés basse et des
cinq semaines les gars n'y a pas ou
quasiment pas de rtt
ils prennent en moyenne 27 jours de
congés par an seulement 21 jours s'ils
sont en cdd
on est très loin quand même de la
situation des fonctionnaires 40 jours où
des cadres des grosses boîtes 33 jours
qu'ils sont c'est sans doute plus
familier ça de nos députés alors que
serait le coup il y aurait un coût pour
les entreprises
oui il y aurait un coût mais un coût
modeste en prenant la même indemnité que
touchent les 400000 papa qui prennent
leur congé de 11 jours quand l'enfant
naît tous les ans bah ça coûterait 630
euros par employeur c'est sept jours
supplémentaires sachant que c'est quand
même rarissime le deuil d'un enfant il
ne concerne et cet heureux qu environ
4500 famille chaque année donc le
gouvernement en creux qu'est ce qu'il
dit est dit finalement aujourd'hui les
médecins à cordes des congés des arrêts
maladie c'est très bien comme ça
inutile de changer et c'est là
finalement quelle erreur mais
incompréhensible de cet exécutif
l'erreur politique les députés
c'est l'article 40 de la constitution
ils ne peuvent pas créer
nouvelles dépenses qui ne seraient pas
compensés cette nouvelle dépense là on
parle quand même d'une dépense de 2
millions d'euros donc le gouvernement
ils auraient pu s'ils l'avaient voulu
amender ce texte pour faire porter le
coût de l'extension de ce congé non pas
aux entreprises mais à la sodie des
ratés de solidarité nationale ça aurait
d'ailleurs permis accessoirement que les
artisans les indépendances en bénéficier
il semblait fils y est aussi il se
serait épargné quand même un scandale
public
l'incompréhension est elle d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui que même le medef se soit
appelé à ce que la loi soit revoter
alors cette loi elle va maintenant
arriver au sénat je peux vous pariez je
prends les paris qu'elle sera réécrite
oui faut qu'elles soient réécrites ça
vous à moi je prends le pari aussi
qu'elle se promenait relaxer je prends
le pari aussi qu'elle sera réécrite
cette loi parce que parce que on entend
pourquoi mais vous entendons je me
disais une chose quand même c'est que
les pays de l'union européenne jean à
l'union européenne
chacun des pays de l'union européenne ce
sont des bastions véritablement à
l'échelle mondiale des bastions de la
protection sociale et du bien-être
social et la france particulièrement
dans l'union européenne est l'un des
pays qui a le système de protection
sociale le plus développé certes fallait
jouer parce que là dessus la haie mais
les britanniques à quinze jours les
congés parentaux on n'est pas des
mineurs ont dieu les britanniques
mon dieu mais changer tout de suite le
système de protea les soutiens
britannique autres le français vous
n'aurez plus de dieu pour pleurer mais
vous n'aurez plus d'yeux pour cloner en
enchaîne on enchaîne parce que sinon
n'auront pas le temps de vous soumettre
leurs chroniques bernard guetta le bleu
mais show de camille voulait me
rencontrer mes shows oui tout à fait je
les rencontre et il y a cinq ans déjà à
l'époque je préparais un livre sur alain
juppé et j'avais découvert avec surprise
que michou et alain juppé étaient de
bons amis d'ailleurs alain juppé était
présent ce matin aux funérailles de
michou quand alain juppé s'était
rencontré quand alain juppé était
candidat aux municipales à paris dans le
18e
oui oui c'était avant
hors d'eau en 1983 on lui fait mes choix
mais mijoux m'avait ouvert ses portes
pour nous raconter tout ça servi un
verre de champagne et c'est là que tout
a commencé alors michou il ya le patron
de cabaret l'ami des stars et des
politiques alors oui parce que quand on
monte dans son cabaret il ya un grand
mur un grand couloir tapissé de rouge
avec plein plein de photos en noir et
blanc couleurs avec michou et des stars
michou et dalida michou et alain delon
est aussi michou et des politiques et
c'est cette histoire que j'avais voulu
raconter ce michou politique dans le
magazine du monde il y a un an
il ya d'abord tous ses amis parisiens
dont deux anciens maires évidemment
jacques chirac il l'aimait beaucoup il
avait décoré avec la légion d'honneur
il y avait aussi surtout bernadette
chirac il partageait le même coiffeur le
coiffeur des stars alexandre de barils
regarder sa soeur mon sens c'est bien
cette ressemblance dans le carré blond
immuable elle aussi bertrand delanoë un
des seuls hommes de gauche qui l'a
précise avait passé des soirées
dantesque m'at-il dit à saint tropez et
plus récemment le député du xviiie
arrondissement actuel pierre yves
bournazel qui rêvent parfois lui aussi à
voix haute de la mairie de paris aux
législatives michaud répéter à tout le
monde vous voulez me faire plaisir
votez pour le petit bournazel c'est le
vous plaît à laure michaud il aimait
surtout les grandes gueules et mais
bernard tapie il aimait aussi jean marie
le pen
la seule qui n'aimait pas je me demande
bien c'était anne hidalgo anne hidalgo
qui en vingt ans de vie parisienne
n'avait jamais mis les de vie politique
parisienne n'avait jamais mis les pieds
dans son cabaret et ça ils ne lui
pardonnaient pas alors comment vous
l'expliquez vous ce lien de 1000 chevaux
politique qu'est ce qui le recherchaient
avec côtoyé massa avait un vrai intérêt
de traiter si j'ose dire michou pour les
hommes politiques parisiens et français
alors déjà et connaissez tout le monde
c'était un emblème il aimait lui même se
décrire comme le dernier dinosaure de la
butte montmartre il avait vu paris se
métamorphoser et électoralement c'était
un vrai
relais sans le sait - auprès des
personnes âgées parce qu'il avait michou
il y avait michaud a tourné en campagne
tout à fait et il y avait michou le
généreux qui invitait voilà qui est
invité une fois par mois les personnes
âgées isolées à déjeuner dans son
cabaret leur faisait un déjeuner spécial
auquel j'ai pu assister il ya un an avec
un spectacle qui leur était dédiée et
les petites mamies du xviiie était très
très touché l'apprécié beaucoup c'était
un hommage à sa propre grand-mère une
amiénoise analphabètes qui l'avait élevé
vous lequel il avait beaucoup beaucoup
d'affection ont continué à chanter
cabaret pas cabaret aujourd'hui en tout
cas ce qui vous a inspiré dans
l'actualité bertrand ce sont les gares
parisiennes
ben oui c'est quand même assez tentant
parce que coup sur coup il ya deux
candidats issus de la république en
marche à la mairie de paris qui ont
voulu faire un sort à deux gares
parisiennes la proposition la plus
spectaculaire la plus farfelue on l'a
beaucoup dit aussi c'est la proposition
de benjamin griveaux qui est de raser la
gare de l'est pour en faire un grand
parc
alors j'ai pas parler du fond du du je
vais pas être cruel mais il ya quand
même un curieux décalage entre cette
proposition et la mythologie parisienne
de la gare de l'est elle qu'elle est
utilisée par la chanson alors la gare de
l'est c'est bien sûr la gare des soldats
de 1914 c'est la gare des conscrits
français qui partaient pendant des
générations dans les troupes françaises
en allemagne
mais c'est aussi la gare des ruptures
parce qu'on n'y peut rien c'est comme ça
gare de l'est
on se quitte écoutez
[Musique]
je
toi
pas
[Musique]
c'est
c'est alain chamfort vous avez reconnu
bernard guetta à un mousse juste avant
de vous laisser là bas vous foot mais
votre votre candidat baja malien où ma
question pourquoi j'ai mon candidat du
tout mais pas du tout mais pas du tout
jeune au parti on marche
je suis dans la majorité passionnant
c'est donc à lire les questions
européennes
elle est allée comment cette idée la
gare de l'est central park
écoutez la gare de l'est c'est là où je
prends mon train pour strasbourg le
parlement donc bien prendre le train
allait on compte il n'ya prennent h
alors alain chamfort raconte donc une
rupture sus une gare de l'est
il faudrait quand même imaginer qu'on
détruise ce sublime décor de temps de
magnifiques rupture romantique par une
pelouse
bonjour coach cédric villani n'a pas
beaucoup fait mieux
lui il ne veut pas rater la gare du nord
mais il faut simplement arrêter le
trafic international de la gare du nord
avant le périphérique à la future gare
de pleyel à saint-denis
or la mythologie de la grana c'est
justement c'est pas trés viennent de
très loin les trains qui viennent de
scandinavie figurez vous qu'il ya une
amie qui m'a parlé d'une chanson pour
enfants qu'elle a apprise dans une école
primaire du 10e arrondissement pas loin
de la gare du nord et elle m'a dit c'est
une chanson qui parle du train du pôle
tu peux me retrouver ça ça et j'ai eu du
mal mais j'ai retrouvé mon fils
oui il elle est ici quand arrive le
train du pôle montres contrôle des
épaules livré six drones en passant par
la gare bizarre
donc le train le train d une qui est du
pôle qui passent par la gare du nord
vraiment oui bon c'est la liberté
weight mais en même temps cette chanson
s'appelle les trains de la gare du nord
c'est une chanson de james olivier en
c'est une mythologie extraordinaire
c'est train couvert de neige qui rendent
dans la gare du nord bon il faudrait
abandonner ce rêve là et d'ailleurs il
ya que nous les naïfs c'est à dire les
enfants les chanteurs les électeurs pour
continuer à rêver dans les gares et
d'ailleurs est ce que ce sont vraiment
des trains qui stationnent le long des
quais de gare du nord gare du nord il y
a des bateaux amarrés comme ne l'ont pas
de pot
destination moscou rotterdam ou
rousselot
gare du nord il y a des bateaux des
bâtons des baptêmes attendant les gars
dit c'est une chanson de 2,2 marc robin
un extraordinaire auteur de chansons
par ailleurs un des meilleur biographe
de jacques brel en 1989 y voyez de
grands paquebots landais le long des
quais de la gare du nord et il faudrait
exilés ce rêve ailleurs pour nous
parisiens c'est un scandale
imaginez c'est ccc train là de l'autre
côté du périphérique
pourquoi dans la compagnie a cessé de
rêver en entrant vraiment en politique
bon bah c'est dire en tout cas on
s'accroche quand on vous écoute c'est
passionnant parce que du coup vous avez
un peu moins de temps à l'arrivée on va
faire vite et avec qui alors roger lave
les reboucher un trou avec une ex prof
d'anglais je me suis dit une spéciale
briques site ça tombe bien elle
s'appelle michel victory big three lé
député ps de l'ardèche et elle est très
investi dans plein de choses dans
l'accès à la culture la place des femmes
égalité des chances cetera mais lors le
problème c'est qu'elle est très
traqueuse alors donc quand elle doit
parler à l'assemblée elle est terrorisée
elle a vraiment des salles terrain peu
sa voix etc
même si ça va quand même un peu mieux
qu'au début de sa mandature au fur et à
mesure on se rend compte quand même
qu'on voit là qu'on y va un peu plus
sereinement mais mes premières
interventions j'étais vraiment je pense
que j'ai tremblé énormément c'est
pouvait prendre actualisons ou et à la
limite vous le faites parfois ça
m'arrive vous prenez quoi ça m'arrive de
prendre un car de cars de bêtabloquants
vraiment je sens si l'intervention est
importante et c'est handicapant un
certain moment ça peut être handicapant
c'est la rue pour pour aider michel
victoria rester zen je lui ai fait faire
un petit exercice de pranayama la
respiration ça vient ça vient d'inde et
ça lui a fait du bien regarder si vous
l'avez rigoureux alors on respire sur
trois on expire ce froid
maintenant on inspire sur trois on
bloque sur trois on expire sur trois
[Musique]
alors vous faites ça avant de parler à
l'assemblée merci vous avez détendue
merci vous pouvez le faire ça marche
très bien alors un pays regardent comme
comme michel victoria était donc prof
d'anglais je lui ai demandé pourquoi les
hommes politiques français parce que ça
c'est vrai même ceux qui parlent très
bien comme par exemple le président de
la république ont un accent épouvantable
en anglais ou vous et on voit si souvent
mais ça dépend à organiser des as les
moyens financiers dont dispose peut-être
parce que les français sont un peu un
petit côté prétentieux de se dire c'est
pas à nous de faire l'effort quoi ils
sont car ils ont qu'a essayé on compense
toujours qu'on s'est tous bien faire
qu'on n'a pas besoin de faire d'effort
je sais pas je n'y a aucune raison pour
qu'on ne parle pas bien il ya aucune
raison quoi il suffit de passer trois
mois en angleterre et vous revenez avec
l'accent enfin voila c'est très simple
alors pour vérifier quand même que son
accent était impeccable je me suis dit
c'est l'occasion ou jamais je lui
demande et nous faire un petit message
promotionnel pour les téléspectateurs
anglophones de l 6 pi qui sont très très
nombreux france info talk about the
politic country and french broadcast
programme se battent politics puis pour
la quête mais bravo me cédric daury
s'applaudit mais bravo
camille mais vous arrivez vous avons eu
deux trois mots elle s'est fait une
superbe chaîne en anglais pour la
meilleure en anglais et mes blessures
temps quoi je dois nuit
juste de wii de ce soir merci infiniment
bernard guetta d'être venu sur le
plateau de lcp
merci à vous chers demi chroniqueurs et
merci à vous de nous suivre un peu plus
nombreux chaque semaine me dit on très
bon week-end à tous profiter
[Musique]